[Music]
hello my name is carolina i come from
the czech republic and i joined the
european court of auditors five years
ago
i completed my studies in the united
kingdom and after my studies i came to
work in luxembourg in banking before
joining the court
when i joined myself i was assigned a
mentor and a mentor is an experienced
auditor who is here to help you with
various questions
auditors are basically asked to swap
between the performance audit and the
financial audit after a certain period
of time which is great
[Music]
currently i am part of the revenue team
which
which audits revenue of the own
resources of the european union such as
vit for example
when auditing a specific eu policy or a
program like the erasmus exchange
program for instance it's like
completing different pieces of a jigsaw
of course because we need to install
confidence of people in the eu
policies and the work we do so i think
it's very important
definitely to have a financial
background i would say is an advantage
but it's definitely not just for people
with
finance expertise
i love luxembourg i believe it's a truly
international place to live and
people soon start feeling at home here
if you have what it takes then please
help us
apply and help us to run the eu better
[Music]